we watched a documentary entitled the
making of Citizen Kane mm-hmm and one of
the gentlemen interviewed said for Orson
Welles his greatness was really his
downfall they leaned that he had been
praised from a young age and and great
things were expected of him and the keys
to the studios were basically handed to
a 24 year old boy pretty much and he
threw caution to the wind
this gentleman felt so can someone be
too flippant with things - yeah I think
it's very difficult I am one of those
people that's so boring for film
professor to say this but I think
Citizen Kane is the greatest movie ever
I really do and not because it teaches
you great lessons about film or you know
it the way it handles the spatialization
of time and the dynamization of space
and the juxtaposition of a mentoring all
the fancy up it's just a great
story it's just such a compelling story
and it uses the medium so phenomenally
well I remember it when I was a student
at SC Linden the special effects guy
came in showed how they they did the
special there's a lot of special effects
in Kane and they're very primitive
compared to computer graphics today and
and involving all kinds of tricks in the
lab high contrast and and by packing the
the film and printing and then printing
from the tail end and all kinds of very
very complex stuff I mean it's just the
way it uses the medium is is astonishing
and his success was so triumphant that
it seems to have her DeMeo you really
didn't handle it there terribly well
he's not really Sufi he was disciplined
enough there but afterwards kind of lost
control of the discipline talent is
hugely over appreciated you do need
talent but much more important than that
is discipline and discipline means time
it means giving giving the time to the
thing
and they're not hurrying and he does
seem to have I mean it's a tragic story
I'll tell you he was supposed to teach
here wells and would have had he not
died was all set to teach and the Dean
then told me that he said to him so you
already did for your class and they said
well he's kind of nervous about
everything he's as ready as he can be
but he's gonna nervous why you've what
specific well you've usually taught
before he said no never I've never ever
taught is the first time and it's it
really and you never want them to teach
before and he said almost shamefacedly
that no that wasn't it the problem was
nobody had ever asked them they never
invited them to teach kind of like the
you know the prettiest girl at the dance
they don't the guys don't think she'll
dance with him you know so they nobody
asks her to dance or something like that
he was a law I mean here there he is
I have a picture of malaria is I mean
just to look at this man you can see
he's committing suicide they're here I
mean he must weigh close to 400 pounds
in that picture take a barely breathe
he's obviously full of of disappointment
and self-loathing and a very very
self-destructive guy so I'm to be a
great artist doesn't mean you have to be
that way but to be greater understand
mean you if your art falls into place
that your life will fall into place so I
don't know one you know it's anybody's
guess really what happened to him George
Lucas had a triumphant success when he
was still in his 20s he was already a
millionaire when he turned 30 and he
still managed to do gigantically
creative stuff for many years to come
and I'm sure you know he just sold his
company for I love it four point oh five
billion dollars even just the 0.05 is 50
million dollars
so I don't think now he's kind of a
haunt the guys in recent years I see
George smiling I think he he adopted two
boys 10 12 15 years ago started to make
a life for himself I know from personal
contacts and people to know him and so
on that he really genuinely hated
running the empire it was like a trap
that fortress Lukas you know very
isolating and it can't you know can't be
easy to have that kind of success some
people handle it better than others if
you look at most pictures of George up
to about 15 years ago he looks I mean I
could show you BIOS here in my
bookshelves but they have picture
sections where he's you know on the set
at Star Wars and so on and it looks like
he's about to be let off for execution
you know he just seems seems terribly
desperately unhappy but certainly he's
disciplined in ways that Wells was not
and managed I think to stay successfully
creative in ways that Wells was was not
able but I don't think it flows
necessarily from the success that it has
to be that way
I mean Steven Spielberg has had a
unparalleled success it was more
expensive there as successful than
Steven expensive to and he seems to you
had once marriage that kind of stuttered
but uh you know current marriage is
thirty something years I only met him
once I don't know him I only know of him
but everybody I know who knows and Anand
even for him to know real well he seems
to despite his success to be very happy
guy if if I could put it that way as
happy as an artist can be I mean you
know artists are haunted by the the need
that they have noticed the desire to
create and make no statements if he were
successful as Steven you could gotta be
your go-to and gender a lot of jealousy
a lot of people are gonna want
take potshots antje and so on I just saw
a Lincoln and I was at a screening at
the guild and Tony Kushner was there
Kushner I don't know about you but I
thought Angels in America was a triumph
just a most amazing play my
brother-in-law won the Tony he's an
actor
for the in the Roy Cohn part Pacino
plays it in the movie Lincoln it's a
triumph I you know I'm notorious for
hating all movies and I don't hate all
movies they just say most movies I mean
most art is pretty bad but it's worth it
you see something like Lincoln and it's
worth sitting through 15 stupid movies
to see something that really is
transforming like like Lincoln and
that's pretty bolts even to do whatever
he wants this is a real reach a real I
mean he's he's inviting all kinds of
risky he's not playing it safe he
appreciates that the most hazardous
thing you can do in art is to play it
safe so I don't think it follows that
great success requires you know
disappointment in in later careers
it just happens from time to time Welles
has a unique story I don't know the
whole story of his life but you know um
my wife is a psychotherapist and in
private private practice for many years
and I tend to think the book is maybe
it's her influence but I think the book
is written early it has to do with how
you came to feel about yourself as a
child and then has a lot to do with the
parenting and and so on you know that
it's not success that brings brings
people down some people handle success
very very well
you